I think of what I think of like that you
have to talk to women like children if I
if I say on a show I say you know women
like men with money the men don't go
around and say well it's not all all
women like men with money or like like
guys don't do that but if a girl if I
say hey men prefer thin women there's
always someone that's like well but not
all men like than women and it's almost
like talking like pulling teeth
sometimes or even like trying to have a
discussion about like the abortion
debate right someone always brings up
grape
always even though it's less than one
percent of abortions and so it's like
it's really hard to have conversations
with women without them bringing up the
exception to the rule